As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal. And with seven rewards, I'm just $4.
作为7-Eleven香脆鸡肉三明治，大家总说我说话声音大。而我想说，对啊，我知道。我很脆。难道你指望我咬耳朵说悄悄话吗？如果你想要安静，去喝点汤反思一下吧。就像，我知道我挺难应付的。我大胆，我多汁。给我加点酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一整顿大餐。而且有了7星积分兑换，我只要4美元。
Quiet. No. Krispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 362326, participating stores only while supplies lastly out for full terms. Before we get started today, I'd like to ask you to take a moment to fill out our listener survey. We want to know more about you, what you think of this podcast, and what you'd like to hear more from us.
安静。不。酥脆、多汁，只要4美元？确实。仅在7-Eleven。山谷362326，仅限参与门店，售完即止。详情请查看完整条款。在今天的节目开始之前，我想请大家花一点时间填写我们的听众调查问卷。我们想更多地了解您，了解您对本期播客的看法，以及您希望我们提供哪些更多内容。
So if you could, please go to our show notes at Apple Podcasts, Spotify, or wherever you listen to Speaking of Psychology, or go to our website at www.combeatingofpsychology. And look for the link to the listener survey. We'd really appreciate it. Now, on to the episode. Very few people do their jobs entirely on their own. For most of us, our work is enmeshed with other people's work, and doing our job well often means being part of a well-functioning team. The stakes of teamwork can be high, especially in workplaces where errors have dire consequences
所以，如果您可以的话，请前往我们在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或您收听《心理学热线》（Speaking of Psychology）的任何地方的节目简介，或者访问我们的网站 www.combeatingofpsychology，并寻找指向听众调查的链接。我们真的非常感激。现在，进入本期节目。很少有人完全独自完成他们的工作。对于我们大多数人来说，我们的工作与他人的工作交织在一起，而把工作做好通常意味着成为一个运作良好的团队的一部分。团队合作的利害攸关，特别是在错误会带来严重后果的工作场所，
such as emergency rooms or air traffic control towers. In those settings, a breakdown in teamwork can be the difference between life and death. Over the past decades, psychologists' research has helped organizations from hospitals to military units to airlines develop better functioning and more effective teams. So what does good teamwork look like? What are the key ingredients of a highly effective team versus one that's a dysfunctional mess? And what does good team training include? Do you have to like your coworkers to function as an effective team?
例如急诊室或空中交通管制塔台。在这些环境中，团队合作的崩溃可能意味着生与死的区别。在过去的几十年里，心理学家的研究帮助从医院、军事单位到航空公司的各种组织发展出运作更好、更高效的团队。那么，什么是好的团队合作？一个高效的团队与一个功能失调的一团糟的团队相比，其核心要素是什么？良好的团队培训包含什么？你必须喜欢你的同事才能作为一个高效的团队运作吗？
Is it possible to make any team work together? So what are the differences between working on remote versus in-person teams? Or are teamwork issues the same whether you're seeing each other in person or on Zoom? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Eduardo Salas, a professor and chair of the Department of Psychological Sciences at Rice University. He is an industrial organizational and human factors psychologist
让任何团队一起工作是有可能的吗？那么，在远程团队与面对面团队工作有什么区别呢？或者，无论你们是面对面见面还是通过Zoom开会，团队合作的问题都是一样的吗？欢迎收看《心理学热线》，这是美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是莱斯大学（Rice University）心理科学系教授兼系主任爱德华多·萨拉斯博士（Dr. Eduardo Salas）。他是一位工业组织与人机工程学心理学家，
whose research focuses on understanding how teams work and how to design and implement effective team training strategies. Dr. Salas has co-authored more than 600 journal articles and book chapters, co-edited 33 books and authored two books on team training and the science of teamwork. His most recent book is Teams That Work, The Seven Drivers of Team Effectiveness. Dr. Salas is an APA fellow and won APA's 2016 Award for Outstanding Lifetime Contributions to Psychology. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Salas.
他的研究重点是了解团队是如何工作的，以及如何设计和实施有效的团队培训策略。萨拉斯博士是600多篇期刊文章和书籍章节的合著者，合编了33本书，并撰写了两本关于团队培训和团队合作科学的书籍。他最近的一本書是《高效团队：团队效能的七大驱动力》（Teams That Work, The Seven Drivers of Team Effectiveness）。萨拉斯博士是美国心理学会会士，并荣获美国心理学会2016年杰出终身心理学贡献奖。非常感谢您今天能来，萨拉斯博士。
Thank you for having. I'm thrilled to be here. You relate an anecdote at the beginning of your book where a business leader you were working with said, we don't have time for teamwork here. We have a business to run. Why is it important for organizations to think about teamwork and do you find that particular perspective as common? Yeah, so that's one of the myths out there, right? So in my going around the corporate world, especially most CEOs, most leaders think that they're doing a great job with teams and then, and that they're good team players. However, when they learn about the science and the principles that we have to offer, all of a sudden they say, oh, wow, I didn't know that. Oh,
谢谢邀请我。我很高兴能来到这里。你在书的开头讲述了一个轶事，你合作过的一位商业领袖说：“我们这里没有时间搞团队合作。我们还有业务要运营。”为什么组织认为团队合作很重要？你发现这种特殊观点有多普遍？是的，所以这是外界的迷思之一，对吧？因此，在我在企业界走访的过程中，特别是大多数CEO、大多数领导者认为他们在团队方面做得很好，然后，他们是优秀的团队成员。然而，当他们了解我们所提供的科学和原则时，他们突然说：“哦，哇，我不知道这个。哦，
I didn't think about that. And then they do, they try to do something different. So, so some CEOs and some, again, corporate executives really don't have a good grasp about the science of teamwork and what the science a thing we can offer. So what makes for a good, highly effective team? What have researchers found are the key ingredients needed for a team to function well? Yeah. So, you know, in a simple way, we look for three kinds of things. You know, it's the ABCs.
我没想到这一点。”然后他们会这样做，他们会尝试做一些不同的事情。所以，有些CEO，再次强调，一些企业高管确实对团队合作的科学以及科学能提供的东西没有很好的理解。那么，是什么造就了一个优秀的、高效的团队？研究人员发现团队运作良好所需的关键要素是什么？是的。所以，你知道，简单来说，我们寻找三种东西。你知道，就是ABC。
What are the attitudes? What are the behaviors? And what are the cognitions? So the attitude is, right, the mindset. how the team members think about the collected activity and their motivations and their goals. The behaviors is about the role clarity, who's responsible for what, who's going to back me up, who is going to do what, when. And the cognitions is in general about a shared understanding of the task, a share understanding of the goals,
态度是什么？行为是什么？认知是什么？所以态度就是，对吧，心态。团队成员如何看待集体活动以及他们的动机和目标。关于行为，是关于角色清晰度，谁对什么负责，谁来支持我，谁将在什么时候做什么。认知通常是关于对任务的共同理解、对目标的共同理解、
a sheer understanding of the mission, what is it that we're trying to accomplish? So under the ABCs, there are a set of competencies that affected teams essentially master, and that's what team training does or team work training or some kind.
对使命的共同理解，我们究竟在努力完成什么？因此，在ABC之下，有一套高效团队基本上能掌握的能力，这就是团队培训或某种团队工作培训的作用。
And so we know what are the ABCs now. And you noted in our book with my colleague Scott Tannenbaum, we outline seven drivers, right? And we invoke the seven Cs of teamwork in that book. So is any one of these factors more important than another? What happens if a team is missing one of these drivers? Well, they're all interrelated. and they built on each other, right? So you can, in a way, can compensate one for the other.
所以我们现在知道了什么是ABC。正如你在我们的书中与我的同事斯科特·坦嫩鲍姆（Scott Tannenbaum）共同指出的那样，我们概述了七大驱动因素，对吧？我们在那本书中引用了团队合作的七个C。那么，这些因素中的任何一个比另一个更重要吗？如果一个团队缺少其中一个驱动因素会发生什么？嗯，它们都是相互关联的，并且建立在彼此的基础之上，对吧？所以你可以在某种程度上用一个来弥补另一个。
But at the end, in order to be a well-functioning team, a team that is resilient and that has good performance over time, you need all these ingredients. So what are these ingredients? So let me go through the 70s really quickly and so that the listeners can understand. So the first C is a capability, right? This is about having the right people in the team.
但最终，为了成为一个运作良好的团队，一个具有韧性并且随着时间推移具有良好表现的团队，你需要所有这些成分。那么这些成分是什么呢？让我快速浏览一下这7个C，以便听众能够理解。所以第一个C是能力（capability），对吧？这是关于团队中有合适的人选。
It's about having talented, competent team members. And the first rule of teamwork really is, or one of the rules of teamwork is you cannot be a good team member if you don't know your job. And so you have to have the capability and you have to have that right mix of people. The second C is cooperation. Cooperation is about the mindset. It's about I like being in a team.
这是关于拥有才华横溢、胜任工作的团队成员。团队合作的第一条规则实际上是，或者说团队合作的规则之一是，如果你不知道自己的工作，你就不能成为一名优秀的团队成员。所以你必须具备能力，而且你必须拥有合适的人员组合。第二个C是合作（cooperation）。合作是关于心态的。这是关于我喜欢在一个团队中。
I want to be in a team. I seek the input from others. And I value the input from others. The third C is coordination. And coordination is about the behaviors. Again, who is going to back me up? Who's going to help me? And who's going to do what?
我想加入一个团队。我寻求他人的意见。并且我重视他人的意见。第三个C是协调（coordination）。协调是关于行为的。同样，谁来支持我？谁来帮我？谁来做什么？
And it's really about role clarity. The next thing is about cognition. Cognition is about the sheer understanding of the task. So it's the sheer knowledge that we have as a team in order to execute a task. Then you have communication. Communication is the way we describe it. It's really about the information exchange protocols. It's about the terminology, the clarity of the terminology, the timeliness of the information.
这实际上是关于角色的清晰度。接下来是关于认知（cognition）。认知是关于对任务的共同理解。所以这是作为团队为了执行任务而拥有的共同知识。然后你有沟通（communication）。我们对沟通的描述方式是，它实际上是关于信息交换协议的。它是关于术语、术语的清晰度、信息的及时性。
And then you have coaching. The way I described this is, you know, coaching is about the team leaders. And what we want our team leaders to act in a. sense, it's like good coaches. So what do good coaches do? They promote teamwork, right? They care about the team members. They develop them. And so that's what we want team leaders to act as good coaches. And the final C is conditions. This is about the organizational conditions. It's a similar work, similar term to culture. So this is about the incentives. the reinforcements that leadership, that top leadership,
然后你有了辅导（coaching）。我对此的描述是，你知道，辅导是关于团队领导者的。我们希望我们的团队领导者表现得像，某种意义上，就像优秀的教练。那么优秀的教练做什么呢？他们促进团队合作，对吧？他们关心团队成员。他们培养他们。所以这就是我们希望团队领导者扮演好教练角色的地方。最后一个C是条件（conditions）。这是关于组织条件的。这是一个类似于文化的术语、词汇。所以这是关于激励的。最高领导层在组织中投入的强化措施，
puts in the organization to support teamwork. So, you know, in this seven C is, it's a, it's really not a model or a theory, just a heuristic to organize the body of knowledge that we have under these things. So effective teams have, in a sense, manage the seas, especially the first six Cs, right, the last one being conditions. So, you know, they have the right people, they have role clarity, they have a shared understanding of the task,
以支持团队合作。所以，你知道，这七个C，它真的不是一个模型或理论，而只是一种启发法，用来组织我们在这些主题之下的知识体系。因此，高效团队在某种程度上管理了这些C，尤其是前六个C，对吧，最后一个是条件。所以，你知道，他们有合适的人选，他们有明确的角色，他们对任务有共同的理解，
they have robust information exchange protocols, and they work under conditions that are supportive of teamwork. So in general, that's how this works. So what happens if you, you are handed a team or you are put on a team and you don't really have a lot of power around the selection of who the team members are. What can you do as a person who either inherits or is placed on a team if you're seeing that some of these Cs are not being followed to the letter, so to speak? Yeah, so, you know, there are a number of tools that you can use. you know, in our science, we have uncovered the teams that pre-brief, pre-brief perform and debrief outperform those that don't. So pre-briefing is basically, you know, you just join this team or this team is a little de-jointed. Then, okay, before we perform, before like pilots do,
他们拥有强有力的信息交换协议，并且他们在支持团队合作的条件下工作。总的来说，这就是它的运作方式。那么，如果你被指派到一个团队，或者你被安排到一个团队中，而你对团队成员的选择并没有太大的发言权，会发生什么？如果你发现其中一些C没有被严格遵守，作为一个继承或被安排进团队的人，你能做些什么？是的，所以，你知道，你可以使用许多工具。你知道，在我们的科学中，我们发现进行预先简报（pre-brief）、在预先简报中表现以及进行事后总结（debrief）的团队表现优于没有这样做的团队。所以预先简报基本上是，你知道，你刚加入这个团队或者这个团队有点散漫。然后，好吧，在我们表现之前，就像飞行员所做的那样，
before they go to the cockpit or before the flight, they pre-brief. And they talk. And they about, okay, where are we headed? You know, how are we going to communicate? Who's going to do what? So, you know, this pre-briefing, if you have the chance to do that, allows you to clarify roles, to get an idea who's going to do what, who has what knowledge, who has what expertise, how we're going to communicate, and then you perform, right? You do the task.
在他们进入驾驶舱之前或在飞行之前，他们会进行预先简报。他们会交谈。他们讨论，好吧，我们要去哪里？你知道，我们要如何沟通？谁来做什么？所以，你知道，如果你有机会这样做，这种预先简报可以让你澄清角色，了解谁将做什么，谁拥有什么知识，谁拥有什么专业知识，我们将如何沟通，然后你就可以去执行，对吧？你来完成任务。
It could be an hour, three hours, a few days, a month, or whatever. But at some point, you need to debrief. And debriefing, like my colleague, Scott Tanenbaum says, you know, is the most powerful, simple intervention yet underutilize to learn and to improve. So the debriefing is a reflection on what just happened. And in that reflection, usually you need to use, what usually happens is you try to understand what things you need to improve, what things didn't go well, and what things you need to change. And so this cycle, again, of pre-briefing, performing, debriefing is usually a good
这可能是一个小时、三个小时、几天、一个月或无论多久。但在某些时候，你需要进行事后总结。正如我的同事斯科特·坦嫩鲍姆（Scott Tanenbaum）所说，事后总结是最强大、最简单但却未被充分利用的用于学习和改进的干预措施。因此，事后总结是对刚刚发生的事情的反思。在反思中，通常你需要使用的、通常发生的情况是，你试图了解你需要改进哪些事情，哪些事情进展不顺利，以及你需要改变哪些事情。因此，预先简报、执行、事后总结这个循环，再次成为一个良好的纪律，
discipline that allows you to, even when you have a bad team or you just inherit a team that is not so good, it gives you the opportunity if you can do this discipline, if you can, this cycle, allows you to learn and to improve and to get the team in line. Now, you've worked in some industries where it's been a challenge to get the leaders to embrace your scientific theories around teamwork. I'm thinking whether that's pilots or in hospitals and emergency rooms, places like that. And then you've run into resistance. How have you dealt with that? Why have some industries been more resistant than others?
它允许你，即使你有一个糟糕的团队或者你只是继承了一个不太好的团队，它也能给你机会，如果你能遵循这个纪律，如果你能做到这一点，这个循环，可以让你学习、改进并使团队步入正轨。现在，你曾在一些行业工作过，在这些行业中，让领导者接受你关于团队合作的科学理论一直是一个挑战。我在想，无论是飞行员还是医院和急诊室，诸如此类的地方。然后你遇到了阻力。你是如何处理这个问题的？为什么某些行业比其他行业表现出更多的抵抗力？
So I started working in aviation a long time ago, 30 years or so ago. And at the beginning, pilots were resistant as well, right? You know, in the early 80s, it was about the right stuff, right? You know, and pilots were more egotistical, to some degree. However, they soon realize that when the plane goes down, they go down with the plane. And so they had to engage. And so 30 years later, I mean, just about all the airlines, whether they're passenger or cargo, really embrace team training and teamwork.
所以我很久以前就开始在航空业工作了，大约30年前左右。一开始，飞行员也很抵触，对吧？你知道，在80年代初，这是关于“具备正确的素质”（right stuff），对吧？你知道，飞行员在某种程度上更自负。然而，他们很快意识到，当飞机坠毁时，他们也会和飞机一起坠毁。所以他们不得不参与进来。因此，30年后，我的意思是，几乎所有的航空公司，无论是客运还是货运，都真正接受了团队培训和团队合作。
They call it the CRM crew resource management. The FAA supports that and so forth. So this generation of pilots completely embraces in general the concept. In healthcare, for example, you don't have that hook, right? So when the patient goes down, unfortunately, only the patient goes down. And so it's taking the health care is taking health care. a lot longer to engage. And the pressure really has come from, you know, the patient safety movement, the number of errors,
他们称之为CRM机组资源管理。美国联邦航空局（FAA）支持这一点等等。所以这一代飞行员普遍完全接受了这个概念。例如，在医疗保健领域，你没有那个诱因，对吧？所以当病人病情恶化时，不幸的是，只有病人病情恶化。所以这需要医疗保健花费更长的时间来参与。真正的压力来自于，你知道，患者安全运动，我们仍然拥有的错误数量，
medical errors that we still have. And really a bottoms up approach, you know, the nurses, the technicians, the people who really quote-unquote touch patients see the need to do. things better for the patient. And little by little, kind of like one team at a time in health care, now, while there's still some resistance, it's a lot less than it was 20 years ago. And the resistance comes from, I see it from two angles. One angle is a financial angle, which most CEOs, chief financial officers and so forth worry about this. If I'm going to invest in the in team training, what is it that I'm going to get for that investment?
我们仍然存在的医疗差错。这真的是一种自下而上的方法，你知道，护士、技术人员，那些真正“接触”患者的人看到了为患者把事情做得更好的必要性。渐渐地，就像医疗保健中的一个团队接一个团队一样，现在，虽然仍然有一些阻力，但它比20岁时要少得多。年前。而且这种阻力来自于，我从两个角度看到它。一个角度是财务角度，大多数CEO、首席财务官等都担心这一点。如果我要投资团队培训，我从这笔投资中能得到什么？
And it wasn't until a little recently that we were able really to answer that question when we've done a number of team training evaluations, metanalysis that really show the boost that you get out of team training. And so now we can answer that. So we say there's value and there's a performance improvement if you deploy teamwork, this is the benefit you get. And in healthcare, we have been able to show that, to some degree, that hospitals that deploy teamwork training versus those that don't,
直到最近不久，当我们做了大量的团队培训评估和荟萃分析（metanalysis），真正显示出你从团队培训中获得的提升时，我们才能够真正回答这个问题。所以现在我们可以回答了。所以我们说，如果你部署团队合作，就会有价值和绩效提升，这就是你得到的好处。在医疗保健领域，我们在某种程度上已经能够证明这一点，部署团队培训的医院与没有部署的医院相比，
medical error is reduced and mortality is reduced. So there's a link, you know, between teamwork and saving lives. So that has been one. And the second, my opinion, at least in my experience of doing this for a long time now, is if they buy it, they have to deploy teamwork training, they don't know how to do it. They don't know how to implement it. They don't know how to make sure that the, there's so sustainability of the behaviors that the people, the new behaviors and cognitions and attitudes that the staff just got.
医疗差错减少了，死亡率也降低了。所以，你知道，团队合作与拯救生命之间存在着联系。这是一个方面。其次，在我看来，至少在我长期从事这项工作的经验中，如果他们买账，他们就必须部署团队培训，但他们不知道该怎么做。他们不知道如何实施。他们不知道如何确保员工刚刚获得的新行为、认知和态度的行为可持续性。
And so, you know, it takes them some time to get traction to create the conditions, one of the disease, to create the conditions such that people, perceive, teamwork is important, it's reinforced, it, you know, it improves patient safety, it improves patient care, and so forth. So there have been those two lines, you know, what's the ROI return on investment from team training? And then how do we roll this out so that it's sustainable over a period of time and not just a, you know, a one-time event? So what does effective team training look like and how can a company or another organization tell if the team training is actually working? Yeah. So first of all, there are several models out there in the industry.
所以，你知道，他们需要一些时间来获得牵引力，以创造条件——其中一个C——创造条件，让人们认为团队合作很重要，它得到了强化，它，你知道，它提高了患者安全，它改善了患者护理，等等。所以一直有这两条线，你知道，团队培训的ROI投资回报率是多少？以及我们如何推广它，使其在一段时间内具有可持续性，而不仅仅是一次性事件？那么，有效的团队培训是什么样的？公司或其他组织如何判断团队培训是否真的在起作用？是的。首先，业界有几个模型。
You know, the medical community created a team training program called Team Steps with DoubleP, one word together. And to simplify any training, not only team training, but any training at the end of the day, does four things. It gives you information, demonstration of good behaviors by behaviors, give you opportunity to practice, and you get feedback. So information, demonstration, practice, and feedback. So these team steps and in other systems that are out there, by and large, have those four components, right? And so you learn about the team principles. You look at videos of good teams and bad teams and you can analyze them and, you know, and extract what good and bad about each of these video tapes, for example. then you get opportunities to practice,
你知道，医疗界创建了一个名为TeamSTEPPS的团队培训项目，两个P，连在一起的一个词。为了简化任何培训，不仅是团队培训，任何培训归根结底都做四件事。它为你提供信息、通过行为示范良好的行为、给你练习的机会，以及你得到反馈。所以是信息、示范、实践和反馈。因此，这个TeamSTEPPS和现有的其他系统，大体上都有这四个组成部分，对吧？所以你学习团队原则。你观看优秀团队和糟糕团队的视频，你可以分析它们，你知道，并提取这些录像带中每个团队的好与坏，例如。然后你获得练习的机会，
you might role play, you may use a simulation, and so forth, and then you get feedback on that. So training or team training that has those four elements have a higher probability of transfer or training.
你可能会进行角色扮演，你可能会使用模拟等等，然后你就会得到关于这方面的反馈。因此，具备这四个要素的培训或团队培训具有更高的转移可能性，或者说培训迁移。
In other words, that people will apply the skills they just learn back to the job. However, you know, just deploying team training, you know, it's really not enough. There is a science of training as well in the science of training tells us that there are things that you need to worry about after you, before you deploy the training, after you deploy the training thing.
换句话说，人们会将他们刚学到的技能应用回工作中。然而，你知道，仅仅部署团队培训，你知道，这 realmente 还不够。培训也是有科学依据的，培训科学告诉我们，在你部署培训之后、在你部署培训之前，有一些事情你需要担心。
So before you deploy the training, you need to prepare the organization for the training. You train supervisors. You make sure everybody's on board. to that. And actually most team training or most training fails because the organization is not ready to receive that training. So, and then you have to worry about afterwards, right? Do you, are you supportive of the skills that the competencies that the people just got? Do you reinforce that?
所以在你部署培训之前，你需要为组织做好培训的准备。你培训主管。你确保每个人都在这方面达成共识。事实上，大多数团队培训或大多数培训都失败了，因为组织还没有准备好接受该培训。然后你必须担心事后，对吧？你是否支持人们刚刚获得的技能和能力？你是否强化了这一点？
Do you give an opportunity to perform? Do you, you know, measure them this new new competence? So, long story is good team training. You need to worry about things that you do before the team training, things you do during the team training, which I just explained the information of the training practice, and things that go after training. Now, there have been many evaluations of medical team training and other team training
你是否提供表现的机会？你是否，你知道，衡量他们这项新能力？长话短说，好的团队培训。你需要担心你在团队培训之前做的事情，你在团队培训期间做的事情——我刚刚解释了培训的实践信息——以及在培训之后要做的事情。现在，对医疗团队培训和其他团队培训已经进行了许多评估，
and two or three meta-analysis, and for the audience, a meta-analysis and integration of many findings, a quantitative integration of many findings. This meta analysis clearly show the benefit of team training. It boosts performance, reduces errors, people are more engaged, people are more satisfied. It creates innovation in things of that sort. How important are individual differences such as personalities in determining how well a a team works together. I mean, are there really some people who just aren't team players or can
还有两三个荟萃分析，对于观众来说，荟萃分析是对许多发现的综合，是对许多发现的定量综合。这些荟萃分析清楚地显示了团队培训的好处。它提升了绩效，减少了错误，人们更投入，人们更满意。它在诸如此类的事情上创造了创新。个体差异（如个性）在决定团队合作的好坏方面有多重要？我的意思是，真的有些人就是不适合团队合作，还是几乎可以指导、教导任何个性组合如何一起工作？是的。我拥有的最简单的例子是我们大多数人，嗯，不是大多数人，我们所有人，都有这种倾向。要么我们是集体导向的，要么我们是自我中心的。如果你是集体导向的，你喜欢在团队中，你想在团队中，并且再次强调，你寻求并重视他人的意见。自我中心的倾向是独行侠，无论你做什么，都不参与集体活动的人。
pretty much any group of personalities be instructed, taught how to work together? Yeah. The easiest example I have is most of us, well, not most of us, all of us, have at this position. Either we're collective oriented or we are egocentric. If you're collective oriented, you like being in teams, you want to be in teams, and again, you seek and value the input from others. The ego-centric disposition are the long walls, people who don't engage in collective activity, no matter what you do.
所以在团队中，你需要具有集体导向的人。你知道，我给你一个我喜欢使用的体育例子，非常喜欢用。所以迈克尔·乔丹，你知道，史上最伟大的篮球运动员之一。在他的传记中，他承认你知道，当他是
So in teams, you need people who are collective-oriented. You know, I give you a sports example that I love to use, love to use. So Michael Jordan, you know, one of the greatest basketball players ever. In his biography, he acknowledges that you know, when he was
芝加哥公牛队的一员时，他说直到他们在公牛队得到了斯科蒂·皮蓬（Scottie Pippen），我们才开始赢得总冠军。在不了解斯科特·皮蓬的观众中，他是一名退役球员，
part of the Chicago Bulls, it wasn't until he says until he wasn't until we got Scotty Pippen in the pools that we began to win championships. In the audience who doesn't know about Scott Pippen, he's a retired player
现在，但他是一个伟大的防守球员。得分不高，但他助攻最多。他经常传球。所以他在某种程度上是集体导向的。所以球星或团队需要一个能够传球的人。在团队中，你需要这个。你需要一个会传球的人。所以这是一个，这是一个。
now, but he was a great defensive player. not a high score, but he had the most assists. He passed the ball a lot. And so he, in the sense, it was collective oriented. So the star or the team needed somebody that would pass the ball. In teams, you need that. You need somebody who's going to be passing the ball. And so that is a, that is a.
你需要具备的倾向。现在，有一些研究表明，以自我为中心的个人在某些情况下会参与集体活动。当这些因素不再存在时，他们又会恢复到以自我为中心的性格。所以你只需要找出这些条件是什么。现在，在过去三年里，许多人已经转为远程工作，远程团队与面对面团队工作有很大的区别吗？
a disposition that you need to have. Now, there's some research, however, that shows that egocentric individual under some circumstances engaged in collective activity. And when those factors are no longer there, then they go back to being egocentric. So you just have to find what are those conditions. Now, many people have made the switch to working remotely in the past three years, are there big differences between working on remote teams versus in-person teams?
是的。在我看来，最大的挑战是建立联系，简单来说。所以，你知道，我们从讨论ABC开始这次讨论，对吧，态度、行为和认知。所以在远程环境中，甚至在Zoom中，在。你知道，你如何保持这些联系、行为、认知和态度？这相当具有挑战性。而且，你知道，你如何保持信任，对吧？所以，在某种程度上，科学可以帮助同地办公的团队和分布式团队，或者在某种程度上看不到对方的团队。
Yeah. The biggest challenge is making connections, in my views, to simplify things. So, you know, we started this discussion by talking about the ABCs, right, the attitudes, behaviors, and cognitions. So in remote, in a remote setting, or even in Zoom, in. You know, how do you keep those connections, the behaviors, the cognations, and the attitudes? It's quite challenging. And, you know, how do you keep the trust, right? And so, in a sense, the science helps you, helps collocated teams and distributed teams or teams that don't see each other in a way.
只是有时，当你是分布式团队时，某些C更重要，也更具挑战性。分布式团队或混合团队面临的最大问题或最大挑战是信任。我如何，你如何，需要这种相互信任，以便你可以拥有某种心理安全感，心理安全感就是你敢于直言不讳的许可。对吧。非常快地，你知道，所有团队迟早都会陷入冲突。解决冲突的方法之一就是这种心理安全感。你必须能够就某事进行艰难、困难的对话，而没有任何后顾之忧。这就是分布式团队或看不到对方的团队的困难所在。
It's just that sometimes some of the Cs are more important and more challenging when you are distributed. The biggest problem or the biggest challenge that distributed teams have or hybrid teams is trust. How do I, how do you, this mutual trust is needed so that you can have some psychological safety, which is psychological safety is the license that you have to speak up. Right. And very quickly, you know, all teams sooner or later engage in conflict. In one way to resolve conflict is this psychological safety. You have to be able to have hard, difficult conversations about something without any repercussions. So that's the difficulty in distributed teams or teams that don't see each other.
他们如何建立这种微小的信任，以便他们能够相互了解？我见过这样的例子，例如在银行中，当他们的团队分布在世界各地时，他们试图创建活动。他们称之为饮水机活动（water cooler event），对吧？所以当你去饮水机旁时，你和你的队友进行了10分钟、5分钟的对话，谈论一些可能与工作有关的事情，对吧？你知道，你这个周末做什么了？我的孩子在做那个，诸如此类的事情。所以这些团队试图创造这种饮水机活动。我见过他们，例如，当他们，我帮助过的一家银行，
How do they create this little trust so they can get to know each other? I've seen examples where in banks, for example, when they have teams that are distributed over all over the world, they try to create events. They call this the water cooler event, right? So when you go to the water cooler, you have a 10, five-minute conversation with your teammate about something that had time to do with the job maybe, right? You know, what did you do this weekend? My kid is doing that, that kind of thing. So these teams try to create this water cooler event. I've seen them, for example, when they, one of the banks that I've helped,
周一早上他们开第一次会时，他们轮流在团队里发言。每个成员总是花大约五分钟时间。就这样，五分钟谈论他们的孩子们或者他们做什么，周末做了什么，其他事情。这有点像打破僵局，也是为了了解你。随着时间的推移，它建立了这种信任。有没有这样的地方，例如，你可以去那里做团队建设练习，绳索课程，类似的事情？
Monday mornings when they have the first meeting, they take turns around the team. And each one of the members always takes about five minutes. And that's all, five minutes to talk about their kids or what they, do what did they do during the weekend, something else. That's kind of like to break the ice a little bit, but also to learn about you. And then over time, it creates the stress. What about there are places, for example, where you can go and do team building exercises, ropes, courses, things like that.
我的意思是，这听起来与饮水机的主意相似，但有点不同，因为你真的置身于工作场所之外，你可能在做一些看起来有点危险的事情，你可能不得不依靠你的同事之一来确保你不会脸朝下摔倒。这会造就一个更高效的团队吗？还是这只是有点像，你知道，我们其实只是在玩乐，然后我们要回去，变成一个糟糕的团队，和以前一样？好吧，让我告诉你这个故事。在我看来，团队建设和团队培训是有区别的。团队培训。
I mean, are those that sounds similar to the water cooler idea, but a little different in that you're really outside of the workplace and you might be doing something that looks like it could be a little bit perilous and you might have to depend on one of your coworkers to make sure that you don't fall on your face. Does that make for a more effective team or is this just sort of, you know, we're really just having fun and then we're going to go back and be a bad team, the same that we were before? Well, let me tell you the story. So there's a difference between team building and team training in my mind. Team training. It's about getting team competencies, you know, the C's or the ABCs that I talked about.
它是关于获得团队能力，你知道我谈到的C或ABC。所以它是关于团队能力的。团队建设就像你刚才描述的那样。你知道，你去了北卡罗来纳州的某处荒野，在那里美酒佳肴招待三天，你做任务，这与工作有关。这实际上是关于角色清晰度的，这是最大的好处。因为在这三天里，同样，你和你的队友享受美食，在这个过程中，你们会谈论彼此是做什么的，你们会了解这一点。所以大约20年前，可能需要更新，我做了一个团队建设的荟萃分析，再次强调，是对团队建设的定量综合，我发现它与绩效的相关性很小，很多顾问对此并不喜欢。但是，但是，但是团队建设有其好处。你知道，你获得了这种角色
So it's about team competencies. Team building is like you just described. You know, you go into the wilderness of North Carolina somewhere and you're wine and dine for three days and you do tasks and I do with the job. That's really about role clarity, the biggest benefit of that. because during those three days, again, you're one and nine with your teammate, and along that way, you're going to talk about what each other is what you do, and you're going to learn about that. So about almost 20 years ago, maybe it needs to be updated. I did a meta-analysis of, again, a quantitative integration of team building, and I found very little correlation with performance, which a lot of consultants did. didn't like. But, but, but there's a benefit of team building. You know, you get this role
清晰度，你对你的队友了解更多等等。但团队培训是关于能力的。这是非常不同的。所以这两者都有其一席之地。只是你需要确保你了解各自的好处。我想问你的背景和军队经历是如何影响你作为一名心理学家的工作以及你对团队的兴趣的？当然。所以我为海军工作了15年，当时我被雇佣去建立一个团队绩效实验室。有趣的是，为了和我招募的同事以及学生一起做到这一点，我们需要让自己沉浸在海军陆战队员、
clarity, you learn more about your teammates and so forth. But team training is about competencies. It's very different. So that the two have a place. It's just that you need to make sure that you understand the benefits of each one. I want to ask you how your background and the military influenced your work as a psychologist and in your interest in teams? Sure. So I worked for the Navy for 15 years and I was hired to develop a team performance laboratory at that time. And interestingly enough, in order to do that with my colleagues that I recruited, and students, what we needed to do is immerse ourselves in the context where the Marines,
飞行员、女兵们正在执行任务的语境中。所以我在军队工作中学到的是，为了提供帮助，为了解团队做什么以及他们需要什么帮助，我需要了解语境。让自己沉浸在他们所做的事情中。所以美妙之处在于，在过去近40年的职业生涯中，最令人满意的的事情之一就是，当我试图帮助组织时，我和我的同事把自己沉浸在语境中并去学习，你知道，我们与他们一同挥汗如雨，我们，你知道，我们起得早，我们睡得晚，无论有什么需求。
airmen, women were performing. So what I learned working for the military was that in order to help, in order to understand what the teams do and the help they need, I needed to learn the context. embed myself in what they do. So the beauty, one of the most satisfying things on my career over the last almost 40 years now is that when I go and try to help organizations, I embed myself and my colleagues in the context and learn, you know, we sweat with them, we, you know, we wake up early, we stay late, whatever the demand is.
我早期在军队里学到，当你，你知道，我们起早贪黑，你。与他们一同挥汗如雨，然后他们就会听你说话。他们会尊重你。你不是那种象牙塔里的教授或任何做研究的研究人员。所以当我在1999年左右离开海军时，我把这个经验带走了，并说，你知道，如果我要学习，我和空中交通管制员一起工作过，我在医疗保健、银行工作过。为NASA，我的意思是，你知道，石油和天然气，你知道，我让自己沉浸其中然后学习。然后你就可以把干预措施语境化，然后运用我们所知的心理学原则来适应他们的环境。这产生了巨大的影响，因为他们懂了。
And I learned that in the military early on that when you, you know, we wake up early, you. sweat with them, then they listen to you. And they respect you. You're not this ivory tower professor or whatever researcher doing things. And so when I left working for the Navy in 1999 or so, I took that with me and said, you know, if I'm going to learn, I've done work with the air traffic controllers, I've done work in health care, for banks. for NASA, I mean, you know, oil and gas, you know, I've embedded myself and then learn. And then you can contextualize then the interventions and then use the psychological principles that we know to adapt to their environment. And it has a tremendous impact because they get it.
这是他们的语境。但是，你知道，但我们使用的心理学原则在某种程度上贯穿了所有这些行业，只需将其实际语境化。这就是我在军队里学到的。这是，我称之为与他们一同挥汗如雨。如果一个团队陷入冲突并陷入僵局，似乎真的没有有效地运作，会发生什么？
it's their context. But, you know, but the psychological principles that we use kind of cross all these industries, by the way, it's just a you contextualizer. So that's what I learned in the military. It's, you know, I call it sweating with them. What happens if a team falls into conflict and gets stuck? And it really doesn't seem to be working effectively.
有没有一些技术可以应用来解决它，或者你只是把它炸毁并说这个团队根本不行？嗯，辅导是其中一种，你知道，如果你能获得外部视角，那就是一种。另一种方法是，你知道，我又从我的同事斯科特·安纳马（Scott Annamar）那里学到了这一点。有一种技术，如果你能参与自我诊断的技术。所以你通常可能会问三个问题。你知道，作为一个团队，我们有哪些事情需要停止做？作为一个团队，我们有哪些事情需要开始做？
Are there some techniques that can be applied? to fix it or do you just blow it up and say this team is just not going to cut it? Well, coaching is one of the, you know, if you can get an external view, that's one. Another way is, you know, I learned this from my colleague Scott Annamar again. There's a technique, if you can engage in a technique to self-dict. So you usually ask maybe three questions. You know, as a team where things we need to stop doing, as a team where things we need to start doing,
以及作为一个团队，我们有哪些事情需要改进？所以如果你有心理安全感并且敢于直言不讳，那么你对你的团队进行这种诊断：停止、开始、继续，你就会发现哪里出了问题，是什么造成了冲突，以及我们需要做哪些事情。以确保我们不会进入这种模式。所以是有这种技术的。只是，再次强调，你必须具备这种纪律，好吧，让我们谈谈这个，对吧？
and as a team where things we need to improve. So if you have psychological safety and you can speak up, then you do this diagnosis of your team, stop, start, continue, you'll find out what's wrong and what creating the conflict and what things we need to do. to ensure that we don't get into this mode. So there are technique. It's just, again, you have to have the discipline of, of, okay, let's talk about this, right?
让我们认真对待。团队运作得不好。你知道，我们没有照顾好病人。我们没有做好任何事情。你知道，我们表现出了不安全行为。让我们，我们需要做点什么。所以暂停。让我们谈谈这个。
Let's get serious. The team is not functioning well. You know, we're not taking care of the patient. We're not doing whatever. You know, we're exhibiting unsafe behavior. Let's, we need to do something. So time out. Let's talk about this.
然后你说，好吧，我们需要停止这样做，开始继续。每个团队要有效运作，都必须有一位指定的领导者，还是说这可以是一个随着团队工作而转变的角色？是的，不。事实上，我发现在医疗保健领域，共享领导力可能是在某些团队中运作的一种方式。
And then you say, okay, we need to stop doing this, start continuing. Does every team to be effective have to have a designated leader, or is that a role that can shift as the team does its work? Yeah, no. Actually, I've seen in healthcare, share leadership is probably, it's a way to function in some teams. you know, if you get, you know, the OR is one example of that, right? At one point,
你知道，如果你得到，你知道，手术室（OR）就是其中一个例子，对吧？在某个时刻，
the anesthesiologist is leading. Then it might be the technician and then might be the surgeon and then back to the anesthesia. And so, so no, I don't, you know, more and more jobs
麻醉师在领导。然后可能是技术人员，然后可能是外科医生，然后又回到麻醉师。所以，不，我不知道，你知道，越来越多的工作
and more and more teams have shared leadership. You know, somebody with, with the, right expertise steps in at the right time to lead, to facilitate and into the last question. What are you working on now? What are the big questions you still want to answer? What motivates me now after doing all this work for all these years is
以及越来越多的团队拥有共享领导力。你知道，具备正确专业知识的人在正确的时间介入以领导、促进——最后一个问题。你现在在做什么？你还想回答哪些大问题？在做了这么多年所有这些工作之后，现在是什么在激励着我？
what are the organizational conditions that are needed so that the behaviors, cognitions, and attitudes are sustained over time? So how do we create organizations? How do we design organizations? How does the leadership that the C-suite needs to act and what things they need to do in order to ensure that the behaviors, that teamwork is sustained over time? And it becomes part of the DNA of the organization, right? It gets ingrained. So I think that's one of the biggest challenges.
为了让行为、认知和态度随着时间的推移而持续，需要什么样的组织条件？那么我们如何创建组织？我们如何设计组织？C层高管需要采取什么样的领导方式以及他们需要做哪些事情，以确保行为、团队合作随着时间的推移而得以持续？并且它成为组织DNA的一部分？它深入骨髓？所以我认为这是最大的挑战之一。
But these days, I mean, there's all kinds of technologies going on. There's human automation teams, they're human robot teams. They're robot-to-robot teams. And so now there are other, you know, I'm not an expert in those. But I know there are there, there's a lot of interesting in this kind of teaming, right? with AI, with automation, with a robot. And so that's also the kind of questions that other scientists, scholars are trying to answer,
但现在，各种技术都在发展，有人机协作团队，有人机协作团队。有机器人与机器人的团队。所以现在还有其他，你知道，我不是这方面的专家。但我知道有，人们对这种组队方式很感兴趣，对吧？与人工智能、自动化、机器人一起。所以这也是其他科学家、学者试图回答的问题类型，
you know, how do you mimic, how do two robots mimic teamwork, all the things that I've talked about to some degree? And so, but to me, the things that interest me is, are those conditions in, And it translates the science, the psychological science that we have, the principles that we have so that people can use and apply and improve their teams and their lives and so forth and so on. So that's what terms me on this day, is the translation. Well, this is all really interesting.
你知道，你如何模仿，两个机器人如何在某种程度上模仿团队合作，我所谈论的所有事情？所以，对这些事情感兴趣的人是我，是那些条件，并且它转化了我们拥有的科学，我们拥有的心理科学，我们拥有的原则，以便人们可以使用、应用并改善他们的团队和他们的生活等等。所以这就是今天让我兴奋的事情，是转化。好吧，这真的非常有趣。
I very much appreciate you taking the time to talk with us today. Thank you, Dr. Silas. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And again, we'd like to hear from you about what you think of this podcast and what you'd like us to talk about more than we are now. So please go to our website, speakingof psychology.org, and look for a link to our listener's survey. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts,
非常感谢您今天抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢你，萨拉斯博士。谢谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 www. speakingof psychology.org 上找到《心理学热线》之前的节目，也可以在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到。再次，我们希望听到您对这期播客的看法以及您希望我们讨论更多内容。因此，请访问我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org，并寻找指向我们听众调查的链接。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，
you can email us at speaking of psychology at a.pa.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyyan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at a.pa.org。《心理学热线》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔蒂扬（Chris Kondyyan）。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。